hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll if you remember back in the
early gogo youthful days of mindscape we
had Geoffrey West on in episode 5
Geoffrey's an expert on complex systems
and scaling from physical systems to
biology to social systems and one of the
things we talked about was cities and
how the fact that human beings
congregate in cities is extraordinarily
helpful when it comes to generating
ideas innovation progress the number of
patents per person is much higher in a
city than in rural areas for example not
just because there are more people but
even more per person today we're gonna
talk about cities or urbanization more
generally as engines of actually
protecting and preserving the
environment so the idea is not only that
is moving into cities and good for human
beings we talk to each other we
experience diverse at possible outcomes
and we have good ideas but it's even
better for the planet to have human
beings in cities this can seem
paradoxical but I think that we'll try
to show you that it's not and I should
say also we're not trying to have an
agenda that cities are the best I happen
to live in a big city but I appreciate
all the listeners no matter where they
are Farms houseboats mountaintops you
can listen to mine scape from anywhere
you want today we're going to talk about
ecology nature conservation with Joe
walleston Joe is a conservationist and
naturalist at the Wildlife Conservation
Society where he's the vice president
for field conservation programs and Joe
spent numerous years working on
conservation of nature in Africa and
Asia and other spots around the world so
he's not exactly an anti nature city boy
but he's done the science he's looked at
how human growth has been affecting our
planet obviously it's not all good
climate change pollution are very very
real but urbanization the Joe claims the
fact that people are being concentrated
in cities gives us a new way to live in
harmony with nature really if you if
you're worried about population growth
for example the population of the earth
is still growing but the
rate of population growth is
dramatically slowing at peak in the
1960s and much of that is because people
have moved into cities and are having
fewer children there we might be
undergoing a phase transition from an
exponential growth phase we're just
having more and more people to a new
phase where there's a certain fraction
of the earth taken up by human
settlements but it's mostly urban and
nature and all the different species on
earth can survive in harmony with us at
the same time that's what we're gonna
get into we're gonna talk about all
those issues it may or may not be true
but it's certainly food for thought as a
reminder you can support mindscape by
pledging on patreon at patreon.com slash
Sean M Carroll and I very much
appreciate everyone's support thank you
for all those who have pledged and with
that let's go
[Music]
Joe walleston welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks so much I thought we
would begin because population is
something where people have talked about
it right resources environmentalism
urbanism all these things were to talk
about people had pre-existing ideas in
their head it's not like talking about
the Higgs boson where you can just say
anything so before we go back and lay
the groundwork why don't you give away
the punchline
what is the the sort of elevator pitch
for you're proposing a fairly new way of
thinking about some of these issues so
the the punchline would be that for the
whole entire life of ourselves and the
actual international environmental
movement the earth has been on a steady
decline in terms of nature nature's been
on a decline and all of conservation has
been designed around merely slowing
declines and we really haven't seen any
sort of indication of anything but that
continuation but just as we are really
getting towards the real crux of form
the future of nature and the last
decisions on whether we'll have much of
nature left we're starting actually to
see the the groundwork for establishing
the foundations for a real recovery of
nature and that is now within our grasp
and within certainly the lifetime of
ourselves or possibly our children and
yet it is quite possible for us to
ignore it and therefore miss that
opportunity but overall an optimistic
message its overall an optimistic
message not a inevitable message okay so
there is a there's a ring that we can
grasp for and maybe get it absolutely
all right
so great they said this is something
that we should all be hearing about I
think why don't you tell us your
background what you your job is right
now so I'm the senior vice president for
global programs at the Wildlife
Conservation Society
so WCS is a it was the old New York
Zoological Society which was was
involved in much of the early
conservation work in North America and
then some of the founders of the
international conservation movement
early on has two arms runs the five zoos
and aquaria min in New York okay
I'm including the Bronx Zoo and Central
Park
in the New York Aquarium and but also
has this international conservation arm
right and it's that eye that side I work
for and I run their global program and
the does this come out of an academic
background get a PhD and things like
that become no no I was I was always
told at school you could never do in
wildlife or animals as a job and that
was big enough to be very early on and
ended up doing interested in in
mathematics and early on and then
actually went back into a further degree
in in zoology and only after I
discovered other people doing zoology so
but you always loved the animals that
was an early goal it was yeah it was a
very simple one I've always loved
animals and never managed to shake it do
you think that the mathematics has been
of any help you we tell ourselves in
physics certainly that the rigorous
training that we give our students is
useful no matter what you end up doing
I'm I've always found it interesting I'm
I would it's easy to overstate how much
it actually does truly help me and in
this but occasionally is useful to say
seek vein of overstating things in that
way alright so then let's set the stage
for our audience's minds about the
conventional story like before we get to
your story there is I maybe it's an
exaggeration but when I think of
population and things like that I think
that either people ignore it or they
basically have a doom selling to do
right like you know that the population
is exploding this is really bad that's
gonna overcome the entire earth so why
would we have ever been concerned or why
should we be concerned you know what is
the conventional worry the the real
warrior and around population is that is
links often to consumption that that
obviously with increased numbers of
people comes increased level consumption
and we live on a limited planet with
limited resources and so consuming food
and that only nature the conversion
consuming capital to to other forms of
capital web sets that's really is that
consumed as a consumption of nature and
so whilst we all can argue about
different levels of consumption on how
it flows or rich and poor and inequality
essentially the more people unless you
see have any sort of insight to
population growth is very difficult to
be able to think about conserve
and sustainable management of natural
resources I think there's probably some
rough intuitive feeling that you know
the earth is finite and there's a bunch
of people it can't grow on forever right
yeah that's exactly and and we all know
that and we've had we've fear right in
the past about where those limits are we
put off on the whole got them wrong at
different points yeah but that doesn't
mean the actual the the the the final
end point which is we do live on a
finite planet and we and until we find
some sort of stabilization of that
population it's gonna be hard to be able
to find strategy sustainability and this
little little controversy that we have
been affecting the planet enormous ly
right there's this word and for piscine
can you explain that to us
yeah the scene is just the is that the
word which I think has merit and holds
up as a description of a planet which is
defined no longer necessarily by purely
g-locked or even climate features but
actually is singly defined by the by the
population of humans and their impact on
the earth we human beings I mean how
much what was the human population a
hundred thousand years ago or something
like that you're gonna put me on the
spot for exactly very very rough order
of magnitude yeah I mean we have you
know we have grown from for for
millennia we have been a we have spread
across the world that's the first thing
the geographical scope is is quite
enormous and we often forget actually
how successful we have been for so long
at distributing ourselves right across
the planet but almost invariably across
the planet for up until incredibly
recently we have always lived in
relative population stability of course
having the Centers of that and there are
many reasons for that not least of
course that we've we've had high
massively high death rates and we'll get
into more of that later oh yeah things
in the control I'm so actually for me
the for me that the distribution across
all habitats and past the world there's
been a more impressive
a movement of people than has the actual
population increase but essentially the
world has started to go through what's
called that you know the demographic
transition right and I don't know if now
is here the place to start describing
that transition so that's the yeah go
ahead and describe it sure well very
basically for um there are depending on
who you are three or five stages but
let's break it down to three stages of
the demographic transition the first one
is um is where really mortality rates
and birth rates have kind of kept tally
with each other and on the whole that
people have lots of kids and lots of
kids die and that's been the feature of
many of our societies for um for
enormous parts of human history the
second phase the democratic transition
is whereby the we have managed to do
some very important but very basic
things we've managed to control some
very prevalent diseases we've been able
to give fresh water or livable
conditions we've been able to get hold
of any of the drivers and control many
of the drivers of that mortality rate
but of course for that phase then you
have you have continued fertility rates
you have people who traditionally still
have 10 12 children and therefore you
have this dramatic separation between
those two levels the mortality rate goes
down the fertility rate stays the same
and therefore populations start to to go
through the roof and then of course the
third phase which is that those same
communities those same societies then
respond and they the natural fertility
rate comes down often people therefore
start to choose to invest more it is in
in invest more and fewer children
so when you say choose this is a
conscious decision or is it just I'm in
different conditions now I don't need
quite as many kids
well if that's something that could be a
conscious decision so that's in the
conditions change and there are many
other factors involved including women's
ability to influence those those factors
it's as a major influence on there but
on the whole that the motivations and
incentives change well and so whether
whether you're in
whatever part of the world there usually
comes with us an incentive to invest
more in fewer children as you have
greater confidence they're going to be
able to live okay that's stage three
that states we have five you could be
five you could do it goes on to where
actually then the the the population
stabilizes and now there's a fifth
theory of what happens at extreme levels
like we're seeing maybe like places like
Japan or some parts of Western Europe
what we haven't really got enough
evidence yet and a long enough time to
be able to demonstrate what happens in
those societies there's some evidence
potentially that those levels go people
choose to have more again but actually
is also similar amount of evidence at
the moment that they go down and
actually there was we're seeing in many
parts of the world and that actually
population natural population levels are
going down so Japan's levels we all know
is population is going down and has real
demographic change it's stable in many
parts of Western Europe and United
States but that's primarily because of
immigration hmm and that factors again
into into all of these these arguments
so yeah I want to get deeper into this
but there's an aside because I was
zooming around one of the websites you
sent me to look at global population
over time and and the Year 1500
surprised me a little bit because there
was a map of the world and all these
different countries color coded on how
populous they were and sort of the
obvious population centers in Europe and
Asia yeah right
but then there was also pretty deep blue
and present-day Mexico yeah and it
reminded us that you know the Aztecs and
maybe the descendants of the Mayans and
so forth there were a lot of them we
kind of got rid of a lot of them right
but human beings have been very good at
spreading themselves around the globe
not just in reproducing themselves they
happen and and yes and we're only still
only discovering just how successful
many of these and is these populations
were at both at establishing themselves
but also managing to work out ways at
which to live at larger population
levels and whether that's through
intensive agriculture or collaboration
cooperation or trade or many of these
other at specialization as many of these
features of so-called you know modern
societies
but of course many them collapsed yeah
and for a wide range not inevitable
they're never inevitable it has a good
human scale thing to remember right
absolutely absolutely and and so but
also none of them have at all through
history ever compared to the now the
populations we're seeing or raising now
and that really has been a shift whereby
we have been able to sustain some
millions of people in cross countries
and city and civilizations at some times
now we're talking about hundreds of
millions of people and billions of
people and sometimes tens of millions
people in very very small geographic
areas yeah yeah and that's really novel
and I think one of the things I learned
from reading your stuff is probably in
the back of my mind even though I'd
never quite articulated this I probably
thought of population growth as
basically a story of compound interest
that there was some rate of population
growth and it grew very slowly for a
long time just because there was a small
baseline to begin with and it didn't
grow that much and we've been growing
for a long time now so now it seems to
be growing very rapidly but that was
wrong right that was really not exactly
an even balance but only a tiny bit of
excess of births over deaths for a very
very long time and it's that gap that
you really refer to we've talked about
this more I think right now
the change that happened in society
drove the death rate down long before it
drove the fertility rate down and that's
what led to this absolute spike in the
in the population growth rate absolutely
and that's um it is it it takes them
this is where we know you do need
demographers and your DD statisticians
to be able to explain it because it
doesn't sound initially intuitive and
and yet when you see it and so
that'sthat's always new I start off with
just to surprise people and get people's
attention and is they would ask them
when when the rate of the human
population was at its highest the the
increase in human population rate was
its highest and people often say about
now or last year or years ago and it was
around about 1962 the world's
the rate has come down of increasing
abound since then but that doesn't say
much about actually how the absolute
population has increased authority to
write and so you know it is as you say
it is at that gap and where we were
phenomenally successful at different
points of overcoming major global
influences on the mortality rate and you
know and when we whether it be the
invention of penicillin or whether it be
the understanding of just the germ
theory and being able to get of these we
always forget just how many people died
yeah we die a lot yeah and and cities
themselves were just were just clusters
of death in many ways I mean could we
still wipe out half the population of
Europe at certain times and yeah Spanish
flu and all these others and so it's
when you suddenly remove that almost I
mean in terms of in societal moments and
a blink of an eye the impact that has in
contributing to the the the world's
population suddenly starts to become
more logical and rational doing and it
wasn't from the graphs I saw it was
until around 1920 that the population
growth rate really took off and it
peaked around in the 1960s and that's a
fairly short window in which it was
going crazy it's still a little bit
crazy right now but it's way lower now
than it was in the 60s yes absolutely it
is it is way low it is significantly
lower and it was up to 22.2% and it's
it's it's way down now and of course
it's different over different regions
but that's the other that's the other
thing a fascinating facts about this is
is how brilliant we were even as in a
global community way back in why I said
way back in the in the turn of the 20th
century and and into the 19th century is
about sharing discoveries and this is a
wonderful thing you know we when we did
actually discover a you know penicillin
or germ theory or these others of course
it didn't get to many areas that still
needed it and suffering continued way
beyond longer than it absolutely
should but we should also another hand
recognize just how brilliant we were of
distributing it worldwide and and then
the the other thing was is how societies
have around how slowly though they did
respond to that change we didn't
recognize it for a long while we didn't
know the implications of it for a long
while and the other one which we'll get
into a bit later is we assumed that
somehow people would behave differently
in different parts of the world and this
is one of the things I've always been
going on for many years and haven't had
no evidence do to back it up before
which is the commonalities between
people you know I've lived in many very
very different cultures to the one I was
brought up in and yet it was always very
striking and the same cultures were both
foreigners like myself and and the and
the people I live with would always say
honor but my society is very different
my culture is very different and always
know and I was never convinced about it
and now we see this that wherever you
are the world the commonality between
these trends what's happening in in
China what's happening in sub-saharan
Africa what's happening in Latin America
are incredibly similar and actually we
are a lot more similar than we are
different and that's not just a social
soundbite that sounds yeah yeah no
that's very good learn it and it feeds
into the obvious question of like let's
be a little bit more careful about why
the population growth rate is going down
so there's a lot of factors absolutely
and this fact that it happens more or
less universally in different places
speaks to some universality right in
what the factors are they're like the
top two or three factors that are the
most important ones in your mind yeah
well this comes to a really interesting
point of the research because I think
for us I my my wife's flavor interest in
in women's rights and maternal health
and for many years and when we lived in
Africa and Asia and and she was always
working you're an understanding what are
the most effective drivers to support
women in the in greater influence over
their matter
for their own decisions over over
families and children especially and
what we see is you know whilst some
attempts were very comfortably specific
or some what the overriding influence or
a huge influence underestimated
influence is purely the nature of
urbanization urbanization urbanization
what happens in the urbanization process
I often thought that urbanization as
many people thought was just a feature
of economic development as and but I
think what's underestimated is actually
what happens in urban environments
I think immediate access greater access
to education to basic resources and
sanitation to the ability to the
reduction in mortality levels and
therefore the inclination to to invest
more the cost of education and yet the
impact of a good education I mean you
still know you can still get in bed
highly educated in many rural areas of
the world and have no sort of social
mobility and chances are I should be
increasing that in city that really does
open it was more leverage for education
when you're in a city there's a lot of
opportunities and a lot of diverse
things that you could do absolutely and
yet many of us have this preconceived
ideas of we look at these them or even
slums and we look at cities and we look
how filthy disgusting they are and we
look at these bucolic scenes and the
countryside and look how lovely well
just take a look at this numbers take a
look at the stats you know you do not
want to be poor and in the countryside
okay um it's great for us when we get
our second houses and and we want to go
back and we're living in a high
governance environment and that's great
but you do not want to be poor or a
woman in in those environments and
actually the stats on everything from
child mortality to abuse to women's
rights they're much worse in these areas
than cities even sometimes you know
these low-income what slum areas what
happens in them is a fascinating the
evidence of how they mobilize and change
how people's decision changes and how
people access the ability to be able to
move socially is is is quite stark and
there's another aside but I think it's
worth one worth getting to then we'll
come back to the cities and population
growth but
you touch on the idea that there is a
moral aspect to how people think about
these things right I mean maybe moral is
even too strong but there is a romantic
aspect of living in the countryside
living off the land and so forth and
people who are not professional
demographers or population geneticists
and so forth
might think that there's just something
better about having fewer people living
in agrarian societies Thomas Jefferson
would have fun this right and and
vice-versa there's other people who
think that emic economic growth is the
best and you know Steven Pinker has
taught us that economic growth gets the
side of everything and people objected
that and back and forth like how much of
this so number one how much of this do
you have to confront when you're talking
about this and talking to other people
number two how much work do you have to
do to control your own cognitive bias
these this way and make sure you're not
just figuring out the result you want
and then saying that's what we should do
yeah well if of course I have I've
complete access to the truth in a more
Boston anyway actually it is helpful
when you yeah people like you don't you
know what so first of all the overriding
thing for me that the simplest thing for
me is in all this is I think it's about
choice and I think the most interesting
thing has been where has been the impact
that has happened globally when
societies especially governments have
actually given choice to to their people
so you know post Hanuman square really
then and what happened then and it put
the fear of God into the into the
Chinese government much their response
was around you know a couple of things
or was around nationalism and also
around wealth creation and one of the
things they did there they just made it
easier for people to move and Lane
trappings you know efforts to be able to
free up the control they had about that
and what do people do they did what
people do everywhere in the world is
that people were nice move to sit and
they moved to the cities and then
China's they moved to the coastal cities
predominantly but elsewhere in African
governments when they and and elsewhere
when they had forcibly moved people or
to borders because of course people
often do that to protect
and fearful all across Italy well not
just Africa and they put people in in
god-awful conditions and displaced for
for that and they're kept there for
generations and yet when people relax
those moves what do people do they move
yeah and it's the greatest indication of
what is I think probably what is right
is actually just looking across what
happens when people a have the charm of
their choice and be most importantly
what as importantly have the ability to
take advantage of that choice it's all
very novo of they have a choice but if
you can't afford to move or if there are
other things keeping you there then you
know then then it's worthless and so
that's really what's happened in much of
the world in that part of the message
and and nothing this disparagingly at
all this is a Pro Liberty Pro capitalism
kind of thing that you know letting
people be the individual makers of their
own choices can make things better for
everyone so absolutely you want yes the
the amount of the nature in the
direction of criticism sometimes to some
of these arguments is been interesting
it's sometimes very hard to get back to
the facts and the issues at hand because
again people see their own politics
through some of these facts but it's
right I mean you know a lot of our work
is building on demographers and
professionals in in this very I think
fascinating realm and people like Brian
O'Neill at the University of Denver
people like Branko Milanovic who have
done a lot of work understanding both
the economics of and the demographics of
this and what's what's really and this
for me was it was a great eye open at
the the menorah that the paper that we
did Eric Sanderson is a is actually an
urban conservationist and he he wrote a
fascinating book on mannahatta what what
Manhattan was like before it became an
happen and that done becoming their head
still and then actually that's a lot of
a first of his work and actually to
continue to conceive of what it could be
like and what we could do but also sorry
I had no experience and no off cities
I've lived my life
in in Cambodia and Gabon and Vietnam and
Zambia and places like that and and so
I've come from looking at the countries
about going through their transition and
watching and looking at societies
through that so the coupling with people
like Eric is I think about cities and
what happens within cities really has
been the the real change and I think
these what the demographers have really
done have come up with these shared
socio-economic pathways I what the world
probably could look like in in and and
this is so important to all of our work
is very very few industries where but
maybe your own where this isn't that
yeah this isn't actually I'm an
important feature to understand
well yeah it's great so that brings us
exactly back to where I wanted to pick
up I asked what are the most important
causal factors helping lower the
population growth rate and one might
have guessed if you need to pull on the
street people would have said things
like health care education just overall
economic wealth but your first word is
cities yeah the first word I'm and it
really is it is not because it is the
the only thing out there but it's the
thing that both are almost it's almost
ubiquitous feature of all these trends
that are that are going on around the
world at the moment because also they
have a number of features that we tend
to see as a consequence rather than as a
cause exactly right so all these things
I just mentioned maybe you're going to
say come out more naturally or at least
more readily when we're in this urban
environment yeah so I mean take take
take um I'm an issue of our female
empowerment is a crucial one I mean the
world's population is going to be
influenced by a billion people according
to whether or not we educate sub-saharan
African girls over the next thirty years
and that to me as a friend is an
astounding fact sub-saharan Africa being
the area of the world where the
population was still going like
gangbusters really that is about to hit
its second phase demographic transition
where it's it's it's just about to get
gonna stop dying as quickly but they're
not gonna stop having kids right away
that's right they are already you know
and
you know for a bunch of reasons
have-have for external the internal
reasons have been delayed in the into
hitting the demographic transition
they're going to be going through the
population rate is still going up not
just the absolute population cities have
historically not being great urban
creators of jobs and these and ideations
and all these features and yet they are
starting to now they there's going to be
a huge increase there's going to be a
massive reduction in poverty as well
it's going on already I'm sorry I should
have said I mean the reductio vertie
levels in in sub-saharan Africa against
many people's awareness are actually
going down quite considerably and it
fantastically and they're going to
continue to go down even though the
population is going to go up that's most
of people's prediction is that America
urbanizing rapidly not as rapidly as men
as many other areas and their transition
might be slightly slower and have a
different you know there might be
different cadence to the development but
essentially it's the same transition I
mean one of the one a things we come out
at the very end of this will be that
know the one of what the world really
needs to do is help African cities
function right my goodness if you could
make African cities work and function in
the way that you know my adopted city
New York or Shanghai or many of the
other sees also some positive African
city examples already can do in place
like Kigali or some of those areas that
will have an enormous impact on a whole
range of factors this a political
governmental challenge it is everything
from just a municipal just getting the
amenities that it is a governmental
infrastructure in very its its key goes
this goes all the way from very very
basic things like transport giving I say
simple of course it's not it's highly
complicated but on the concept at least
is very simple you know water or
sanitary sanitation rain transport
housing all those things all the way up
to having a civil society that is both
demanding and voting and advocating for
these things right okay but you think so
you think it is happening but that is
it's interesting as a scientist it's
fascinating right because you get to see
the thing that we went through a couple
hundred years ago and it's going through
so forever in Africa now yes any menu
and it's not as if we're devoid of
examples I mean Rwanda really is a
fantastic example of of a country that
has faced monumental challenges and you
know and setbacks in yet with a highly
highly dense popular human population it
is managed to restructure and work
itself through this transition at the
moment it's more ahead of the curve than
the many sub-saharan African countries
even though it doesn't quite have the
necessary the natural resources of a
Botswana or a South Africa or many of
these other other countries and so
there's again this other argument which
I reject which is that somehow there are
circumstances which are make it makes
Africa any different right okay that's
very interesting and also so I just want
to go back to this I'm not you my my
mind is not letting go of this issue of
the causal factors because they are all
it's all back and forth right I mean
presumably urbanization depends on
wealth and education and things like
that like what makes people decide to go
to the cities so again I think many the
reasons people get a system first of all
but with predominate talk about you fear
is that you know you're you look at I
was up in in the borders of the China
Russia border where we for many years
been trying to work on wild tigers in
those areas and and on the Russia side
they've got the Tigers and China really
they've had this population which is
always an understandably consumed a lot
of the the the prey base of tigers and
they've lived up in the border area
Security's been as big and now that's no
longer a lot of those areas of being
deep naturally depopulated of people of
people because the youth are moving away
and you've got these rather I'm in fact
frankly a rather sad populations up here
just remnant people who are they're just
going to aged out of the population but
the youth move for for obviously access
to to jobs the ability for social
mobility for a whole range of of
opportunities that are presented in the
cities now we might still think they are
terrible abusive places for those areas
but this is actually the economy's come
from these areas they generate the
middle classes the
the urban middle classes are almost
invariably across the world the single
greatest drivers for good for social
change in countries whether they be in
totalitarian countries whether there be
in all others and so yes there are
negative aspects we should not really we
should not ignore that there are social
inequality aspects there are a whole
bunch of other issues in there but they
the what we are seeing across the world
is that these this process of people
choosing to move creating wealth moving
through society having greater traction
and influence over their governments and
ultimately where the environmental
movement comes from we should always
never forget they're not rural movements
and I noticed that that was hilarious
that basically all these great
conservationist movements come out of
big cities yeah absolutely a New York
you know in the Roosevelts and the
erector and there were they were no
wealthy influential urbanites who
basically and we shouldn't have just and
all the elites the the middle classes
around the world when I first understood
just this one one story when I first as
a as a basically a kid I went and I went
to Southwest India as my first act real
exploration into conservation and I
almost quit right there and then I
almost went back in because what I saw
in in the in in India and just outside
Bangalore and in Connecticut was was
these tiny almost remnant pockets of
nature stuff with largely a small small
numbers of tigers and elephants in that
surrounded by this sea of poverty I mean
it really was depressing it was it was
deep nothing it was it depressing and as
a as a privileged guy from you know from
from from from England to be able to see
it was it was shocking but the real
depressing thing was that that I saw no
future I didn't see how it is gonna get
worse yeah and what hope with these tiny
islands you know even if I didn't have
any sort of moral quandaries about
what's happening with the human
population just a biological one what
was what was the future were these just
these those last remnants and then I was
would also read things like the the
people who established Yellowstone
National Park
in the States and people out there they
were equally dumbfounded they thought
when they established Yellowstone this
was going to be the last remnants of the
West they were down to the last few
hundred bison they were it was the whole
place was just open for was
environmental carnage yeah and their
language was very desperate and what it
meant to be able to save on to these
places and they didn't have a future
either they did it without any sense of
what could be now I went back 25 years
later to to indwell I went back in 20
years ago and 20 years later and and it
was the most encouraging and astounding
thing I've ever seen because not only
was where I seeing Bangalore sure it was
harder for me to get around Bangalore
but let's face it that's a reasonable
thing Zack you Malaysian of people into
the city into an urban Bangalore
I saw poverty rates disappearing down
through the course they're still bad and
they should need to get better but
compared to where they were they've gone
down you've got this it's okay to say
both of those things right you know that
half the poverty I know poverty is very
bad we don't like it we should keep
fighting against it but it's actually
getting better it is a real challenge
you often say something very positive
and people infer that do you have said
something that is against the negative
all the negatives and and so it's a
little boring as to the repetitious
poverty bad you would take talk about so
what we saw what I saw though when was
encouraging is is Nick on one of the
largest markets for Nick on zoom lenses
that had become Bangalore
why because these wealthy middle class
lodging initial the middle class of
Bangalore were now taking these cameras
and going back out to these places where
I'd been 25 years ago and now they were
the ones that are paying for advocating
for voting for nature and it and whilst
for many years it was dependent on
organizations like myself to be able to
prop up the last places where their
societies were had not have could not
afford or were not interested in being
able to conserve these areas luckily not
fully the case in India India's always
had this connection to nature but but
now it was these who have been taken
over by the middle classes and that's of
course what we want
we want these people and they were
connecting up nature and we had for us
we had an ambition of I think 400 Tigers
in this large connected landscape we're
now they're having to double that
estimation of what we should have in
those areas and we're having to readjust
our ambitions for nature in the face of
what was almost impenetrable and gloom
because now these reversals are
happening not just because it freeing up
of space and too many people obsess
about the idea of freeing up space this
idea of people moving off the land
therefore nature can thrive that's an
element of this we could we very
cautious because of course consumption
increases we we could push off our
consumption and pressure agricultural
pressure to somewhere else but the most
important thing is that it produces
these the same environmentalists that
came out of London 300 years ago or new
york city hundred fifty years ago
exactly the same people they're creating
in Bangalore Bangalore Nairobi in these
areas and again points to the similarity
issues and this is you know the punchy
message I mean I think this is sort of
the deep paradoxical thing that comes
through from your work you're basically
saying that cities are really good for
nature and people sort of don't want to
hear that or maybe maybe it's just
because they haven't thought about it
very carefully but there are people you
know the people aren't going away we
don't want the people to go away but if
we put them in concentrated urban
environments then that can help nature
not only be sustained but recover right
I mean there's a race that there is our
extinctions that is also bad extinction
also bad but maybe what we're seeing is
a phase transition from the transition
where there weren't that many people I
mean people were basically another
animal species you know that build
houses and so forth and then there was
this technological revolution the human
population grew enormously but rather
than just growing exponentially in
having more human biomass than the mass
of the earth in a few hundred years
there's a new equilibrium that we can
reach with way more people but still a
whole bunch of nature more or less
thriving absolutely I think I think
there's a there's a few things to unpack
that this the first one about about
people have need to be really aware that
that cities are the greatest drivers are
bringing about a stabilisation of the
world's population and we've really got
to come to terms with that because often
people see almost cities as the as the
as the exemplar of an uncontrolled human
population and yes actually the reverse
and that's that's really one thing we
got to get across now of course I mean
you mentioned I think in the paper
Victor Hugo and Charles Dickens right
we've read these novels about the
terrible conditions in the in cities and
thus that transitional age but it gets
better but it does get better and you
know and and and if it didn't get better
people wouldn't choose to move and you
know and consistent across areas and of
course there are worse cities and you
know if there are there are there are
poorly functioning cities and there are
fantastic cities but essentially even
the poor cities are still magnets and
where people have choices people stay
and even when people have levels wealth
they don't necessarily leave they move
in the city and they of course they but
they also advocate for better cities and
and that that's a transition that really
is very influential that a transition
from having no traction and though in
influence to more and how one uses that
to improve the quality all environmental
movements came actually from the brown
what we call in brown environment which
is pollution so essentially people moved
to cities massive wealth is creation but
with that was a lot of pollution and it
made those conditions miserable and then
those same people that benefited are now
suffering from that started advocating
for better environmental conditions and
as that that grew out so it spread out
into the green demanding nature and that
again so there is this necessary
transition of course we'd look if we can
find ways of skipping that or hastening
that transition or erect yeah
but immediately again maybe there is
some you know policies that make it
happen faster right no they're
absolutely always and we and we don't
have to return the mistakes but
essentially we have cut we have and this
gets back also to the poverty issue
which is cities drive people out of
poverty know these drives it you know it
is be very hard to imagine China
which has gone which has been the sole
responsibility for the greatest number
of people moving out of poverty in the
history of mankind in the in the last 30
years it is very hard to imagine how
that could have possibly been done in an
agrarian society well in fact the
previous 30 years were not kind to China
and largely some of that was forced
agrarianism absolutely and even in a in
in in our own you know so so in many
ways their policies weren't actually set
they didn't know how it was exactly
going to happen but they did know that
they needed to uncouple it to allow
people to have greater volition and and
and that was a very smart decision and
everyone panicked about the one-child
policy and the rev that the revocation
of that and in China you know luckily
overwhelmed yeah that's that yes
absolutely but by by by the processes of
urbanization and wealth creation it but
so people fixate too much about the
wealth creation which is a bit very
significant but I do want to move a if
it's okay on to the impacts of that not
yet I have a point to make which I think
you like actually a couple points one is
I had Geoffrey West on the podcast he
was an early guest and he loves making
this point about how ideas and patents
and insights grow super linearly with
population density that you know and
let's let's let ourselves be a little
bit romantic not about the countryside
but about intellectual life right and
one of the wonderful things about cities
is by bringing different people into
close contact with each other physically
as well as socially and so forth new
ideas are struck right and that's yeah
that's a that's such a pleasant happy
story in my mind I just want to keep
saying it over and over again if you're
going to agree now I couldn't remember
very hard to discourage every Westerner
little stuff is it work is fantastic and
and scale especially and others but yeah
I mean yeah you know we call it ideation
the ability to to share I mean it is a
fundamental feature of humans is that is
that we know the reason why we have
either made so much progress or and some
people's eyes so much destruction is
because we learnt
how both both to store information and
to be able to share information and
whether one language or whether one
talks about other mechanisms that really
is a so central as to the pace of human
development and cities are extraordinary
to be able to do that you know what
every country I've lived in and I've
lived in a very very different countries
to Des Moines for most of my life the
trends the same country country people
are a bit slow and a bit directly slow
well they know that the jokes around
might yeah I'm one of my my pet my
interest is always listening to how come
getting the jokes of any country I live
that and what they make fun of and who
they make fun of and how they do and of
course it know most of this unrepeatable
but but now there are certain
commonalities and they of course not
because there's any actual difference
people oh there's the same people but
because the it be the longer estimate
how much access they have to how much
information and how smart people are
being able to filter and take
information for their own interests and
even when they don't realize it and of
course cities are just the great drivers
of it ideation and the increase in
populations as as he doesn't far more
eloquently puts in his work the great
drivers of these of thought processes
and of course are amazing at sharing and
again and that's the big thing anyone
can you know that yeah historically
people can have ideas and keep it to
themselves and and people can still make
great bit profit from it but it is all
linked to being able to share that
information and an insights and there's
a wonderful thing there's a natural
question which I also asked Jeffery I'll
ask you to is there a sense in which or
the respect to which the internet and
the increased connectivity between
people will start playing a role more
globally that cities have played
traditionally in that respect yes I
think it's I mean I think it's all very
much part of the same I think they
they've appeared as little islands you
know there's a physical issue of feet of
of cities and there's a technical issue
of internet and actually but actually
what's happening is they're blurring and
all these difference between
the connections we're making I'm we're
obviously speaking in a very delicate
time where whether social media and the
use of news and information and and is
is we're just only now exploring the
dark side of it and the negative aspects
of this but still it is massively
outweighed massively outweighed by the
positives there were poor houses in
London Charles Dickens enticed me yes
exactly and so whilst terrible ideas can
be shared more readily as well we just
need to make sure we understand that far
more scary at the moment is is being
able to slow down those positive ideas
for the the fear about those the
negative eyes does that suggest that we
should be even more enthusiastic than we
are about bringing laptops and Internet
connectivity to sub-saharan Africa
absolutely I think again I think we
should be you know we should be
providing any sort of options that they
choose to be able to and again for me
it's about choice it is not telling
anyone what they should or should not do
certainly not sub-saharan Africa there's
not been a great history of that in the
past and you know and I mean the hope
that make some choices for them so but
my confidence is they're going to choose
very similar mechanism but Amit but also
they have the chance many ways to
leapfrog whole generations of things
that are no longer useful I mean I know
I was living in Africa
cellphones came and completely jumped
fixed-line young systems in many parts
not all but was many poss-eye
and what amazing thing to do and
actually they were at the forefront in
Africa still is very much at the
forefront of using technologies in
social ways and us learning from that
and that's I think that that's going to
increase dramatically I think the
learning is is going to come way when in
two ways now but our only thing is we
should continue the communication keep
all lines open and of course this gets
still gets eventually back to the
immigration question sure
yes do you want talk about the
immigration question or where do you
want to go I wanted to ask you about
inequality so maybe that was in part of
where you wanted to go anyway no you
know I mean wonder so I just want to you
know be I've been agreeing with you too
much here and let's just imagine what
the disagreement would be I mean
wealth creation happens in cities sure
but couldn't one make the argument I'm
not sure if I believe it we couldn't
want make the argument that
stratification also happens maybe we
mentioned Manhattan and I can certainly
see if you drew or fifty years from now
no middle-class people can live in
Manhattan right it's becoming a
playground for the wealthy is that bad
yes I mean inequality is definitely an
issue it's one of the it's got there's a
lot of debate around and it's quite it's
a very valid debate and again I'm gonna
slightly make you wince a little because
I'm gonna say it's good and it's not a
bit bad but it's because of course one
can look at it in two very distinct ways
the the level of capture of the the not
0.1% or whatever it is over the last few
years has been phenomenal unprecedented
and and we we can only begin to
understand what the implications of that
kind of capture of wealth really is and
I don't claim to know or sit here and
and espouse on that but but maybe that
is something where rather than letting
nature take its course this is an
obvious place where the government could
help fix things a little bit right could
be and this really does get outside of
you know really my other applications of
that but I would like to say that that
one also it's got to recognize and
they're not untighten related is that
those same drivers that have caused the
creation of wealth and however it's been
captured that we can talk about about
anyway have fundamentally driven
hundreds of millions and billions of
people out of extreme poverty and if one
looks at the work of our of Milanovic
and and others who have looked at
inequality and some of these very
impressive
reports that have come out on this they
have you know again they indicate two
very separate things and we can debate
how set but they actually are but you
know do what does one in it what does
one measure inequality from the absolute
lowest of the absolute highest does one
do it from the top 5% to the bottom 5%
you know you can measure in many
different ways and sometimes it can look
at polling and ugly and sometimes it can
look truly glorious if one looks at
inequality as literally how many people
you know if you know the worst case
surely will people getting rich from
people getting poorer
that would be the ultimate West and
that's not happening but that's really
not happy the poor are getting less poor
in an absolute sense absolutely and and
that is that is in terms of numbers of
people that is much higher than the
actual capture number of people who are
disproportionately profiting right in
front from and much of that is driven by
Africa in Asia right which aspect of it
sorry the the fact that poor people are
coming out of poverty yeah I mean yes
but I mean yes those are the two large
regions although of course within those
that those regions Asia is a it has this
great difference between historically
still wealthy countries like Japan and
elsewhere and some of the poorest
countries in the world so it's much more
diverse than say sub-saharan Africa and
of course Latin America has had a
significant variation as well but yes
the the real move out of poverty has
been purely numerically has been out of
China and East and Southeast Asia I mean
can we imagine that poverty will
literally end someday that we don't
always have this inequality
well there's absolute you know if you
look what stuns me like yeah the one of
things I often show people as a chart of
what's happening to poverty around the
world and I say look just the two things
to look at why not just look how
incredibly steep that drop-off is in how
however you measure it you know if you
know I have a long argument about
whether it's 11.5 dollars two dollars a
day and how we measure extreme poverty
however you measure it the drop-off is
extreme and how ubiquitous it is and and
if sure it is slow in some areas it's
not just that someone was clever in some
country it seems to be once again a
universal aspect of this kind of process
yeah absolutely and that's that's so
encouraging to be able to see and again
it's got to be it's such a massive
influence on my business I worrying
about the future of nature and resources
I'm just continuously stunned at how few
people actually are aware of this
understand this and are willing to
actually to debate the implications of
this but the the drop of an extreme
poverty you know when the international
community came around and set what's
called the sustainable development goals
now they looked at in 1/2 in poverty
doing it they did it yeah a lot of
things because they set the message she
died of worry for that and now they've
had to revise it and now they're doing
to actually eradicate extreme poverty
now when I was a kid those kind of
things like were a joke he said though
would you want world peace or would you
want you know eradicate poverty they
were kind of like it would never happen
and I think you go back to the 70s you
go back to the 60s and you'll be hard
pushed to find the most optimistic of
those professionals and academics who
really could envisage what has happened
over the last few decades okay where did
I cut you off before do you remember we
were in a you draw me drew me into
inequality I drew you name the quality
but there was something wanted to do and
I interrupted you to talk about I forget
what it was anyway but I could just keep
asking questions okay okay so what is
the future that we're imagining here I
mean people are moving into cities Isaac
Asimov and his foundation series
imagined that the galaxy was ruled by
Trent or a whole planet with nothing but
cities on it is that your goal is that
would you want walleston I would like to
see you know I think that's a really
interesting question because I think I
don't think it's asked enough which is
describe a world of course you know
avoid the kind of cheesy sound bites and
I mean a man living at one with nature
but actually described physically what
actually should do and we should be
doing that a more often which and people
like ourselves should be challenged to
do that more often because we're
terrible we're very good at that saying
what's wrong and we're very bad and good
about telling people how we're the
solution into something which of course
increasingly we're finding is not
correct and yet we're very bad at
describing the world we want to live in
and that should be it and I think for
many of us would actually come across
the same the found out the same
foundations and I think most people
understand and appreciate that that
having a stable human population really
is a goal that we should be looking for
an attainable one amazing that's in that
actually attainable but let's even put
aside at Anil at the moment just for
just but what it would it looks like I
don't think it really that matters if
it's six billion or it's eight billion
or even if it's 10 billion or even it's
12 billion sure they come a different
challenge
is the overriding issue it's got to
somehow stabilize the other one is I
think let's face it we had we should
have no poverty we've got to get rid of
this aside from the moral imperative
that there is also a livability
imperative is that actually there things
that poverty continues to generate and
cause means it will now be able to
achieve many other things if it wasn't
there but of course there is that
overriding moral imperative that we
should have nobody continuing to live in
in poverty and then the third one is and
this relates are both as a cause and
effect we need this connected world no
yes yes of course it we hope to obtain
different cultures and and diversity
within us and we hope that we all don't
just homogenizing it's all the same and
yet the this shared sense of values is
this self-improvement this this drive
towards really does move more smoothing
quickly when when people are connected
and I'm happy together and I think it's
also the one way for us truly to reach a
point where we're making global
decisions about global issues that are
in our shared interests the most of
fragmented ones and I think that's not
just a a rather than you know cheesy
soundbite I think we we I think it's
something we're moving towards
especially so we start to see cities of
city-states reappear now they
disappeared and Renaissance Italy
they're reappearing now with California
as a state starting to make global
climate change decisions we're seeing
New York City's taking up and written
disregarding really what is happening at
the larger national level and we're
seeing this in Shanghai we're seeing
this in many parts of the world and so
that's shifting but that connectivity
those three things those three features
I don't think were very well a pre-work
were were really attainable in many
people's eyes not long ago and I think
not only are they attainable I think
they're happening now it is not
inevitable that's the one thing just
keep saying and this is I'm not we need
to take concerted action debate to make
sure that happen and of course we can
still achieve all those things and
destroy nature mmm and that's the other
aspect of this there's no reason why we
can't stabilize the world that
at 12 million people have people
probably urbanized have people connected
out of extreme poverty and yet there's
very very little of nature left but
let's see we have seven and some billion
people in the world outright so 12
billion is not a crazy number like the
world is still mostly nature compared to
city like what what fraction of the
Earth's laying the surface is covered by
urban environments oh I mean about um I
think it's about five percent I think
the I miss I'd like to get up to seven
percent maybe the next few years
something like that and we're imagining
that that's not just a stepping stone
that could as far as far as what you're
saying is concerned that could be a new
stable equilibrium yeah absolutely it
could it could you have imagined that
most of the world would be in some let's
say under ten percent of the world and
in ten ten percent of the land
it's extraordinary of course of course
there's agriculture and there's
productivity that we could have taken to
account and there's other aspects of it
but yeah I think the scale of these
these these issues and numbers is
something that we've got to get our
heads around of course we should also
fact that people again don't like
sometimes people don't like cities seas
are improving you know my goodness you
you can speak to someone what it was
like to live where I live in New York
back in the 70s and I live in Los
Angeles so yeah there's been a lot of
improvement that's right now he faild
and recognizes and it's not just for
necessarily our protein are our income
levels or either there are areas it's
true for many now of course as soon as
we stop we we start saying that people
imagine that we becoming complacent
about the existing issues and we're not
doing that however cities continue
improve one can imagine a world where by
let's say even 15% of the world is
covered by urban urban areas let's even
20% it doesn't really matter those areas
the possibilities for not just stopping
the decline in nature but then
recovering it across that 80% or we know
we obviously really agricultural and
others is enormous but one cannot do
that if the population continues to to
grow there is no tail off in insight
people and continuing in poverty
remembering that this is the point
actually I wanted to get to which was
when people start consuming when is the
greatest draw
or down on nature is it that is it by me
because in the middle class is moving up
to the upper classes no it's obviously
actually it's a movement of people out
of extreme poverty we use nothing
there's nothing you know the the example
I give is um now you give someone in
poverty a dollar most of that dollar if
not all will go natural resources yeah
food right yeah and and and
understandably so and if on transitions
that you give me a dollar now I will
waste it on an app or I still may save
it or may use it for other purposes and
a far less purport less smaller
proportion of that dollar will go on
natural resources and that's where
really the the consumption curves now
what people that will often criticize
this kind of language and I'll work on
is by saying but you know when people
cities they get wealthy em and they
consume more absolutely but that is a
necessary transition for us to get to a
stage whereby you you have those
foundational situations that you have
the urban eyes you have people's the
world's population state blasts and you
have people over now that comes at a
cost
there isn't a society out there that
hasn't through some form converted
natural capital to economic capital and
driving their economy out of a position
of politic now sure we could find ways
to ameliorate that order to speed up the
process or to lessen the impact but
essentially we have the there is a toll
to be paid now when China went through
when as is still going through but
resident really moved a huge numbers of
people out of poverty there was no
obvious way to do that and in this speed
they done it without having a toll on
nature in those areas and maybe this is
just so obvious we haven't said it yet
but if you have two people of equal
wealth one of them lives in a suburban
split-level and one of them lives in an
urban apartment to the one in the city
is gonna use a lot less electricity gas
things like it's easier to heat an
apartment the news house absolutely I'm
so the stats are you know I live in New
York City again and so the for the
average New Yorker per capita versus the
average American you
that the New Yorker uses 74 percent less
water consumption they reuse 35 percent
less electricity they use 45 percent
less new municipal solid waste ie
garbage per person you know per week and
that's these are extraordinary numbers
right and that by the way that person is
not a better human being there's a
morally superior life but even there's a
vision for for income and meter that
their impacts are are tremendous so yes
there's two things and these are the two
categories cities can be greener and can
be green and of themselves and also
cities have a profound and unrecognized
impact on the rest of the world right I
mean is there still are we never less
helping ourselves to something we
shouldn't hear there's if we have this
new equilibrium where most people are
living in cities and the population is
stabilized but we're still the weather
gradually or not using up some finite
resources here on earth right if nothing
else precious metals we haven't even
mentioned the words climate change I
don't think it's kind of a big deal it
should be those are the dark clouds on
the horizon how worried should we be
about these things yes a lot of a lot of
our papers been written with the the the
tacit recognition of a couple of things
I mean the first one is that the climate
change is the biggest yeah issue facing
our planet today in pretty short term
worrying really absolutely that short
term nonsense it's not also a long term
worry but an imminent war any media well
yeah absolutely and and also that of
course that we know the summer sent that
that technology and those are going to
improve dramatically and continue to
would continue on its existing
trajectory of amazing achievement and
amazing new inventions and that can
often both people think as a as a curse
but often actually it has historically
been a cure to many things now we don't
go we don't follow particularly the
don't worry technology will solve at all
yeah there are people out there who we
have to remember you are a
conservationist by occupation right
though you're not actually like just a
Pollyanna that's a
and but there are people out there who
just say look technologies always hold
something in it'll always solve it now
just because we don't know what it is
that's there there that's not good
enough and that's not sufficient enough
and and and so but no we'd quite
convinced that in a world where people
are educated urbanized connected and in
in that they're going to be making far
better decisions and far better things
on the consumption and the nature of
impacts of these were of this world then
we have done in the past so they're
going to be the they're going to be far
better conservationists
environmentalists whether they live in
downtown Manhattan or at the top of a
mountain in Montana for that makes sense
to me do you have do we have data about
you know the attitudes toward climate
change of urban people versus rural
people yeah yes I mean basically people
in in urban areas are much more likely
to vote with these these issues in mind
they tend to be the the founders of a
lot a lot of central use and a lot of
the movements around the environment
they again come from urban areas they
are so you just look at today about some
of the whether it be the plastics
movement which is a very novel thing
coming out of protecting the oceans or
or on climate change and that these
things they are from urbanites in these
areas and so and people you know I
people you look at the number of people
who now choose to have plant-based diets
for the sake of the environment they
there's another very interesting thing
so I'm sorry finished that thought say
they tend to be able to do be overnights
which I was gonna get okay but isn't it
necessary
trend is that people in urban
environments eat more eat more meat
people in rural environments yes and
that but that's that that's the
transition transition so nobody eats
proportionally know that the big
consumption of meat comes at the change
so there's a big change in me too right
comes when you go from very poor use of
course opposed you're almost invariably
cannot eat meat
to effectively some set over the middle
classes let's just use that as a broad
term at the moment when you move out of
poverty and that's when you that's when
most people around the world choose with
the exception of you know big parts of
India and their ISM they shouldn't
really choose to eat meat right that's
what the consumption patterns change so
now of course beyond that the the
increase in wealth level has less and
less impact on the quantity of meat meat
you enjoy I hope the immunity is not
proportional to my income yeah that
would be bad yeah and increasingly what
we're seeing now is a tail off we're
actually seeing more people who are who
are relatively wealthy and ralphie and
you know a obesity used to be a sign of
wealth right yeah and now I know yes I
know look how its reversed you know and
you see a real tail often people who
have more options who are wealthier more
privileged making choices to consume
less meat this is heading home you're
telling me that my voracious meat-eating
is because I grew up in a lower
middle-class household and I've reached
upper-middle class professor demand that
explains that those social conditions
explain my personal choices I'd be less
forgiving in an analysis and I think but
now that you have the privilege in
position well maybe next I will be
making the decision I mean I I think
this is a sidelight of course but I do
know that our current agricultural
practices are an enormous driver of
climate change right maybe they're not
sustainable very long-term I'm kind of
crossing my fingers that scientists are
gonna build better hamburgers in the
laboratory and the petri dishes and so I
won't have to give up entirely but
because I'm not quite convinced by the
moral arguments but I'm not at all
convinced that I'm not just convincing
myself to not be convinced with moral
arguments because I really like eating
good meat yeah I um there's no question
that that food consumption is one of the
greats
is one of the direct drivers of the loss
of nature and we should be very very
clear about that yeah and but it's not
just about purely about wealth there are
plenty of decisions one can make at any
ad except the extreme poor and they said
there are many many decisions that
individuals and cyah teas can take that
have a tremendous impact on the
environment that is not just linked to
increase in wealth and actually the you
know the wealth we've become the more
options we have to be able to choose to
avoid that negative impact so the
biggest driver of deforestation in the
Amazon is not palm oil by an order of
magnitude it is the it is feeding the
beef industry right maybe and and so we
often associated amoment the US they eat
a lot of meat and a lot of that comes
from those areas and of course soy
products which go into cattle lots and
and feeds and both meat and dairy and
and if one one of the challenges that
individuals face with especially with
these large global issues like global
climate change and others is what on
earth can little old me do and there's
never been a bell active AG g problems
so I'd imagine but even you know
personal responsibility I mean you know
sure we can get rid of arm we can we can
take take minor steps but there's a real
phenomenal opportunity that you know if
you want to really make an impact just
eat less meat and I can give you a
metric for actually how that in that
hits water consumption which of course
is a real growing issue of our age how
much acres of forest will be prevented
from being being cut down and you know
you can hear all these stats about well
yes almonds take water and soy takes
water and all those others nothing comes
close an order of magnitude right
to-to-to hitting the the beef and that's
without even considering all the other
climate change impacts of that right and
so and you're not you're being very
careful not to say become a vegetarian
you're saying eating less meat is very
very helpful eating less I think I
probably healthier too oh it's it's it's
it's it's obvious there is a confluence
of opportunity I mean there are three
reasons why people go vegetarian
plant-based or vegan and they are you
know ethical health and environmental
now each of us each of us has different
views on the on the importance of each
of those three and where we sit in those
and almost all of us like myself Connor
sells on and convince ourselves on
others but but what you do have is a
wonderful confluence of by taking a few
common actions which aren't actually
that big one can have impacts on all
three of those straightaway
very good question well that's good
because it's maybe to finish up I like
that you've sketched out a vision for
what the future could be the the good
future that we might be heading toward
and that is an achievable one like from
as you say from the point of view of I
don't know I grew up in the 70s and
there was there was a lot of doom saying
about the environment and population and
so forth and it becomes more achievable
now but we shouldn't leave it all to the
natural order of things there can be
disasters there can be getting there
quicker or getting there slower so what
should be where should our attention go
in terms of doing things in terms of
taking action both individually or
collectively like what policies should
we be imagining supporting to get there
so I am little bit concerned I may have
been guilty of being a little bit too
positive because I can and I want us to
just recognize first off that that
nature is declining at a rate that
terrifying rates at the moment and
extinctions
but extinctions you know it through
through my work I've been I've witnessed
everything from the the last Rhino and
so much running in Vietnam disappearing
to greater progenitors of the domestic
cattle have gone extinct in the wild I'm
seeing you know declines or left right
and center we're still damaging nature
to to into incredible degrees and there
is and I want to repeat this
there is no inevitability about what
I've described like and so everything
from policies on immigration which was
the point I was ruling yeah too
to to the directors consumption of
nature there is quite the possibility
that that countries like Nigeria who go
through it's its developmental
bottleneck as we describe it in the
paper of the next generations and come
out with no nature at the end of it as
it's a race right it's a race is that he
get to this new equilibrium before you
destroyed everything yeah so so my
country England no we went through a
very slow they've actually period
development a small island and came out
and we basically destroyed you know much
of it which is why we love garden birds
and I think is carnival was a badger you
know about me small we did have bears we
didn't have wolves we didn't have all
these things but we did it the America
the u.s. went through its own process
much more quickly and we thought that
was quick until we saw China's yeah and
so and but what the America managed to
do is get much more of its natural
estate through that bottleneck process
that squeezed on nature that helped
drive that massive rapid transition of
urbanization and wealth creation those
areas and it came out at the other end
with large chunks of nature left into it
and that's partly yes you're a big
country but also the speed of that
process hasn't happened and because you
had people who cared enough to go and
and hold on literally just with their
fingernails hold onto pieces of land
pieces of water and the game the
janitors of the environmental movements
now this is what's happening in every
single country to some degree it's
happening in China now people kind of
have this terrible view of of China of
nobody caring you know in China and yet
I work with with a large number of of
Chinese passionate Chinese nationals who
look very very similar to me to those
same people to Muir's and the others of
American environmental movement and also
there's a growing Chinese environmental
movement is a very there's a very
profound growing environment like
Chinese environmental movement now of
course they're doing they they come
often from the brown that a pollution at
the moment you know there's the
government is very very scared and
worried about the social movements being
arranged and around in air pollution one
of the reasons why they're actually
doing quite a bit and they're worrying
about how to deal with with pollution
but but so the inevitability we've gotta
get we got to get out of the way and so
get getting to your question there are
very there are clear things that we need
to be able to do now honor on a
different scales from the from the
global response to an individual
response the first one is not to get in
the way of what's happening conclude in
many ways and we can do this and this
actually does get the immigration
argument the first one is that we should
recognize that we have in many ways been
winning many of these fights over the
last few years and one of the a lot of
the demographers point to these
different scenarios whereby that the
world could just continue to go up the
past 12 billion and beyond and actually
could also stabilize as maybe a nine ten
billion and then come down imagine a
world where we actually ended up with
stabilizing it six or seven billion
people you know but all of those are
subject to influences short and one of
them is the freedom of people to move an
immigration and I don't come from this
from an ideological perspective and and
and preconceived ideas about immigration
and my culture and what's happening to
my culture I can for this purely from
looking at understanding demographers
work and understanding that if we shut
up shop now if we put up walls if we
prevent immigration now not only has it
been many of the features that people
are talking about now but essentially it
will continue to drive up the world's
human population one of the Ansari how
exactly does that work because we're not
giving a release valve to countries that
are in poverty because it's partly the
reason that partly reason because
basically immigration helps and it'll
helps with equilibrium you know it's
like any other pressure you're able to
move around you meant in people then
forms equilibrium
and and weather where there's demand and
people can support them immigration
moves in and people and helps drive
economies and helps and it's a positive
thing all around and of course are
sometimes people are fleeing because of
persecution all those areas those people
when people are in war or stress people
have more children
why because they have great less
confidence that they're any of those
children in a brief that's why we have
Baby Boomers say you know that's why war
actually has very little effect in
negative effect on human population
because the long term for it on Laura oh
absolutely you make up for it more
because you've artificially you create
this scare of people that have more
children and that and that scare doesn't
go down the day that war stops and some
population spikes happen after conflict
so other things we should recognize is
the world is having a lot less Wars and
going back to it the Steven Pinker star
arguments with there's a lot less
conflict than there was sure too much
but anyway I have to say that you think
we've got it out there so but we have
lot less war and that is a phenomenally
important aspect to all this and that's
that's one of the only other regions to
have increased human population
increases is the Middle East mm-hmm and
so you know we this is blood war a lot
of war and so if we can deal with
immigration if we can we can we can cope
with it we can assimilate it and it can
be can remain a positive thing it is the
most significant way to one of the most
significant ways to bring about a
population stabilization and that is
ideologically very challenging to many
mm-hmm yes but it goes along with the
overall philosophy that let people make
their choices let my people make the
choices within countries between
countries where to go where to live some
people make bad choices but that
increased freedom of letting people do
their thing maybe paradoxically or maybe
obviously helps the planet in some way
yes and so I have a very personal
quandary which I challenge which is um
we work with a lot of very extremely
poor people in rural areas in parts of
in the past the developing world our
tradition has always been to immediately
help them with their
their circumstances there and then and
you know and sometimes it can be fairly
weak responses we can help them with you
know we help with maybe with chicken
production or access to Nationals or
fish farming or you know because often
our work is around natural resources and
sustainability of them it's no longer
clear that's the best thing to actually
help people with and we have to really
rethink this is a conservation or as a
conservation organization might need to
help the move you mean it might be
helping people move give them more to
give more options definitely more get
more options and the other one is just
give more options and help them with the
choice they want to make and just trust
in them that they have a better idea of
their own of what's best for them rather
than up and again an ideological or
institutional imperative yeah yeah and
so the the begin it's your other you
know a question of what we need to what
we need to be able to do there's
actually no question the world needs to
pay more attention to more support to
sub-saharan Africa and just because
traditional development has not
necessarily worked or was not
necessarily that effective doesn't mean
that we should not support and help and
it just needs to be different we can see
things changing as you said perhaps it
we can see things we can see things
changing but unquestionably the
education of sub-saharan African girls
is of paramount importance and those
organizations that help get access to
education but also the ability for for
girls and women to be able to use and
and convert that education
it not only happens in in the workplace
and the career wise but also in the home
isn't is that there's a radically
important intervention the world needs
to be able to support a lot of these
very very good local grassroots
indigenous efforts across Africa at the
moment to be able to do so that just
needs to happen and we need to support
that in any way we can and that's me
coming from an environmentalist you know
you know as a wise about elephants and
tigers the the other one is is for us is
to make cities work you know my you know
if you know if you've there are lots of
cities around the world which are really
not not even getting close to optimal
there they're terribly
they're really poorly designed the
government isn't paying half enough
attention to them now and yet we have
unbelievable leadership in some of our
and US cities and European cities doing
phenomenal things at the moment I'm
staggered on something how how
encouraging it is to sometimes look at
Copenhagen or look at even in New York
or these areas and these initiatives
that are carrying on of course some of
them don't work well that's okay that's
a party experimentation and ideation but
and what's happening in these areas now
with these cities which are wealthier
than most nations which are more
certainly more influential than most in
most nations can link up and imagine
what we can do linking New York to not
to Lagos or these areas and literally
helped with the things that have with
with transport with with with water with
municipal supplies we've get waste in
garbage purely to make it more livable
for the people of that country purely to
help them of that that not only enough
itself is a good thing the impacts and
influence that has are enormous and and
that to me is such an exciting and easy
from not easy but a conceptually easy
thing to do yeah it seems like a hard
thing to you know be against yeah I
don't know this is a great this is a
great message I like a little optimism
sometimes there's plenty of things to be
not optimistic about and yeah and
absolutely and I think I like I
personally like Bloomberg's initiative
on c40 in the cities initiative that
that map xx New York map yeah Berg has
basically getting as we see a resurgence
of the city site as I mentioned before
which is I think a fantastic thing I
think cities are that definitely the way
the future in terms also influence
rather than federal governments and he
is helping this movement around these
cities taking the leadership I'm not a
lot of these roles including climate
change and then we get down to
conservation as well because again this
is still at the heart of the reason why
this is what I'm involved in this is
that that is that during the 80s and 90s
often protected areas and national parks
became very unfashionable they were seen
as kind of a bit
Western Western imposed playgrounds and
and fortress conservation in all these
areas one of the weaknesses of there was
never again any narrative what was their
payoff
you just had these islands lots of
people Paul you had these and that that
was it and then the wealthy could visit
them and and and and photograph them and
that was nice there was nothing for it
but now we have this we have the
evidence of across the world these if
we're successful at getting these areas
and species through this bottleneck they
are they're not only going to be just
there in 100 years time they're going to
start coming back they're going to start
research they're going to be the source
site for any source of nature and the
world this is the exciting that the
world you can now start to envision
envisage a world where an a source for
nature actually happens where a recovery
no we have that we have more Tigers in
the in Texas than we do in the wild in
the world there's absolutely no reason
to think that in a hundred years there
might there there might be 10 times the
number of tigers there are now funded
for supported by advocated for voted for
by the peoples of those countries which
historically have been - for
disconnected and it's seen as a
direction a negative to be able to have
those but our so our job now as
environmentalists as conservationists is
to get as much of nature through the
bottleneck as possible yeah and that
will be the defining feature the u.s.
managed to get the Bison through its own
in bottleneck just just barely yes and
now there are hunt aliens or not and
Isaac can he have you in LA I don't know
if you know there's like a mountain
lions that somehow got across the
highway and is living in Griffith Park
and people are very excited excited and
terrified at the same time they're
careful that they're excited yeah and
but we didn't get the passenger pigeon
right the passenger became extinct and
you know what the Bison now if those
people who put them on the train and
sent them to New York City over a
hundred years ago could see it now they
would cry with happiness of what we've
achieved and they'd hug us for what
we've been able to do the people the
passenger pigeon so they go would curse
us out and so what our job is didn't be
able to do is ensure that Tigers
Lyons great apes these icons of nature
these great whales can get through the
bottleneck not because this is the end
point because this is just the beginning
and so we have this terrifyingly
exciting time over the next 50 50 years
of actually this is the defining moment
for nature this 50 years not 1800s not
even 1950 it's now because we've now
India I guarantee you India is not gonna
lose the tiger I guarantee that I could
not guarantee you that if I was here 50
years ago I mean it's a very important
point because it's saying that
conserving this or that species isn't
just a matter that you know we fall in
love with this charismatic megafauna
that there's a specific period in
history where doing this can really do
good can have a huge impact on the
future of the entire ecosystem for the
world absolutely so there's the app
there's the globe coming back to I
should imagine a global climate change
there's a global climate change factor
which is if if we lose this part of the
rest that the large intact forests the
world of the next 50 years
there ain't no way we're gonna hit our
global climate change target right now
forget technology and other than other
ones at the moment conserving these
forests are the the the prerequisite to
all the other strategies working in
these areas but if we lose a Congo Basin
now as it's about to go through its big
demographic shift then that has effect
on every single person in the world and
our global ability to address climate
change and then are completely different
into the spectrum the idea that somehow
these were just of Western luxuries of
us now is being proven demonstrable a
lot wrong as culture after culture is
starting now to value its own nature
appreciate it and for the first time be
able in many ways to be able to say put
their hand up and say no I want whether
it be right I want my mountain gorillas
in Rwanda and as a Rwandan I want you
know these these great whales in my
country and I'm actually going to do
something about it so our job is not
that once that happens
fantastic I'm out of a job and that's
great but my job is now our job is now
to in those areas get as much of nature
through the
so this is actually the good place to
end because as optimistic as the overall
picture may be there's work to be done I
mean there's clearly things that we can
do that will have an impact and we're
not always doing them we got to try a
little bit harder absolutely all right
Joe Boston thank so much for being on
the podcast thanks very much
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]